Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we talk about research on
all kinds of physics simulations, including
fluids, collision physics, and we have even
ventured into hair simulations.
We mostly talk about how the individual hair
strands should move, and how they should look,
in terms of color and reflectance.
Creating these beautiful videos takes getting
many-many moving parts right, for instance,
before all of that, the very first step is
not any of those steps.
First, we have to get the 3D geometry of these
hairstyles into our simulation system.
In a previous episode, we have seen an excellent
work that does this well for human hair.
But what if we would like to model not human
hair, but something completely different?
Well, hold on to your papers, because this
new work is so general, that it can look at
an input image or video, and give us not only
a model of the human hair, but human skin,
garments, and of course, my favorite, smoke
plumes, and more.
But if you look here, this part begs the following
question - the input is an image, and the
output also looks like an image, and we need
to make them similar - so what’s the big
deal here?
A copying machine can do that, no?
Well, not really.
Here’s why.
On the output, we are working with something
that indeed looks like an image, but it is
not an image.
It is a 3 dimensional cube, in which we have
to specify color and opacity values everywhere.
After that, we simulate rays of light passing
through this volume, which is a technique
that we call ray marching, and this process
has to produce the same 2D image through ray
marching as what was given as an input.
That’s much, much harder than building a
copying machine.
As you see here, normally, this does not work
well at all, because, for instance, a standard
algorithm sees lights in the background, and
it assumes that these are really bright and
dense points.
That is kind of true, but they are usually
not even part of the data we would like to
reconstruct.
To solve this issue, the authors propose learning
to tell the foreground and background images
apart, so they can be separated before we
start the reconstruction of the human.
And this is a good research paper, which means
that if it contains multiple new techniques,
each of them are tested separately to know
how much they contribute to the final results.
We get the previously seen, dreadful results
without the background separation step, here
are the results with the learned backgrounds,
we can still see the lights due to the way
the final image is constructed, and the fact
that we have so little of this halo effect
is really cool.
Here you see the results with the true background
data where the background learning step is
not present.
Note that this is cheating, because this data
is not available for all cameras and backgrounds,
however, it is a great way to test the quality
of this learning step.
The comparison of the learned method against
this reveals that the two are very close,
which is exactly what we are looking for.
And finally, the input footage is also shown
for reference.
This is ultimately what we are trying to achieve,
and as you see, the output is quite close
to it.
As you see here, the final algorithm excels
at reconstructing volume data for toys, smoke
plumes, and humans alike.
And the coolest part is that it works for
not only stationary inputs, but for animations
as well.
Wait, actually, there is something that is
perhaps even cooler, with the magic of neural
networks and latent spaces, we can even animate
this data.
Here you see an example of that where an avatar
is animated in real-time by moving around
this magenta dot.
A limiting factor here is the resolution of
this reconstruction - if you look closely,
you see that some fine details are missing,
but you know the saying…given the rate of
progress in machine learning research, two
more papers down the line, and this will likely
be orders of magnitude better.
If you feel that you always need to take your
daily dose of papers, my statistics show that
many of you are subscribed, but didn’t use
the bell icon.
If you click this bell icon, you will never
miss a future episode and can properly engage
in your paper addiction.
This episode has been supported by Lambda.
If you're a researcher or a startup looking
for cheap GPU compute to run these algorithms,
check out Lambda GPU Cloud.
I've talked about Lambda's GPU workstations
in other videos and am happy to tell you that
they're offering GPU cloud services as well.
The Lambda GPU Cloud can train Imagenet to
93% accuracy for less than $19! Lambda's web-based
IDE lets you easily access your instance right
in your browser.
And finally, hold on to your papers, because
the Lambda GPU Cloud costs less than half
of AWS and Azure.
Make sure to go to lambdalabs.com/papers and
sign up for one of their amazing GPU instances
today.
Our thanks to lambda for helping us make better
videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!